so this year's Nobel Prize in Chemistry
goes to two muslin Don paul modrich and
aziz sancar jointly for their
mechanistic studies of DNA repair and
now I welcome to mass Linden up to the
stage
tomas lindahl was born here in stockholm
in this very city he got his PhD in
Stockholm and his very first discoveries
in this field realizing that it's
actually not stable as a walk but there
is spontaneous decay and there must
exist mechanisms to repair and even
going out to find this molecular repair
systems he is now present in the United
Kingdom working at Francis Crick
Institute and Clare Hall laboratories
and I'm very much looking forward to
your lectures thank you good morning
everybody
all macromolecules or to some extent
unstable my own work has focused on the
inherent ability of DNA itself in my own
studies as a postdoc at Princeton
University in the 1960s we investigated
heat induced shape changes and unfolding
of the macro molecular structure of
purified transfer RNA the small RNA
molecules that are key components in
protein synthesis in this time consuming
experiments I was surprised to observe
that my purified tRNA was not only
unfolded at elevated temperatures which
was known but also very slowly
decomposed in an irreversible way I was
advised by colleagues that human fingers
often have substantial amounts of
ribonuclease on their surface that is
the enzyme that degrades RNA and that
the problem might disappear if I
improved my laboratory technique but
that was not a problem I observed that
different preparations of tRNA obtained
by different methods
still remained
with the slow decomposition in the same
way I extended this work to show that
the composition of tyranny involved
destruction of individual base residues
and also involved slow cleavage of the
phosphodiester bonds that link their RNA
no chloride building blocks together
I even published a short report on the
heat induced decomposition of tRNA that
nobody found particularly interesting so
I moved on to another laboratory for
experimental work on Legation and
processing of strand breaks in DNA by
previously unknown mammalian enzymes
such as DNA ligases and DNA EXO noctis's
but I not forgotten the puzzling
spontaneous decomposition of trna when I
moved back to Sweden and obtained my own
research laboratory in Stockholm a
couple of years later I wanted to
investigate if DNA like tRNA was
susceptible to spontaneous slow
decomposition first at least shows a
model of DNA and it looks rather stable
so it was a far-fetched idea that DNA
which is the carrier of the genetic
information in ourselves might be
unstable in the intracellular
environment in order to support such
non-conventional work I did not apply
for a research grant which may well not
have been funded but used some Swedish
funds I'd already been awarded study and
somatic processing of the on a strand
breaks in mammalian cells the initial
strategy was to perform some pilot
experiments on DNA instability and if
the results did not seem promising
quietly buried the project but it turned
out that
although DNA was considerably more
stable than RNA it still underwent very
slow but relevant decomposition in
neutral extra solution together with my
meticulous laboratory assistant Barbara
Newbury I then devised the series of
time-consuming experiments to attempt to
quantitate and characterize the very
slow degradation of DNA solutions and
the physiological conditions
this meant investigating investigating
the stability of DNA at different pH
values and not to dramatically removed
from neutral pH at various elevated
temperatures and at different ionic
strength levels of charged
neutralization in order to facilitate
our analysis most studies were performed
with DNA radioactively-labeled in
individual base residues such DNA can be
prepared from various bacterial mutant
strains with defects in synthesis or
precursors of DNA grown in the presence
of commercially obtained radioactive
base residues the courts of such DNA
solutions were incubated for several
days and then analyzed by chromatography
the most conspicuous change was that
small numbers of base residues were lost
from the DNA in particular the purine
bases adenine and guanine next lattice
so this is going in and it can be lost
if this base sugar bond is cleaved here
here is a summary of here know next the
previous slide please
this one yeah this is a summary of the
different changes that were detected
this is a section of DNA one of the two
strands of DNA with the backbone of
sugar phosphate residues and the
individual bases gone in cytosine
thymine and adenine and the little
arrows I put in here indicate the sides
that are particularly susceptible to
damage their basic sites that result
from the loss of guanyin
and adenine or chemically identical and
they were introduced at similar rates so
to know the identity of a missing base
you have to consult the information in
the opposite strand of the DNA next itis
among that various lesions besides
losses of basis there is also damage to
individual base residues and the most
important one of those is deamination of
the base cytosine loss of this amino
group here this occurs spontaneously in
eighth resolution next like this and
this shows the consequences of this
event the amination of cytosine leads to
a change in genetic specific genetic
specificity coding specificity so the
resulting uracil will then base pair
with the base adenine instead of going
and which is the mate of cytosine so you
have mutation here when i quantitated
all these losses or chain or changes of
information in DNA the numbers were
surprisingly high next slide please
in a mammalian cell there are 10 to
20,000 changes per cell and per day the
most frequent loss of them is loss of
purine bases from DNA but are also other
changes that occurred quite a
significant rate under physiological
conditions these numbers all for the
double-stranded DNA there is some
protection or basis by the double
helical DNA structure while
double-stranded and single stranded DNA
or deep urinated at similar rates
single-stranded DNA is 150 times more
susceptible than double-stranded DNA to
deamination of cytosine and thymine
cytosine
this means that in a transcription are
the active replicating self our DNA
opens up a little bit and there are
about 300 potentially mutagenic cytosine
and FRA methyl cytosine deaminase in
events per day this decay of the
cellular DNA would lead to an
unacceptable deleterious loss an
alteration of genetic information the
answer to this dilemma must be that
there is a correction mechanism in the
search for such mechanisms next slide
please
we established that a basic sites can be
removed and replaced by an excision
mechanism so here is an a basic site a
missing base and a special nucleus an AP
endonuclease Cleaves the DNA at the site
and then an enzyme removes the sugar
phosphate residue which no longer has
any genetic information and the small
gap is generated in DNA which is filled
in by DNA polymerase and finally mended
by DNA ligation in mammalian cells these
two functions are contained the removal
of the sugar phosphate and the feeding
in of a gap or catalyzed by the same
small enzyme DNA polymerase beta it has
two different demands for these two
catalytic events
the same general excision and repair
strategy is used for tire for other
types of DNA lesions such as DNA damage
induced by ultraviolet light as you will
hear from dr. Sonia ro2 correct
replication errors in the DNA as you
will know from dr. knowledge next that
is if the DNA contains an altered base
which is shown on the Left slide here
this is a cytosine that has become a
uracil and now is contained in this
mismatch here G opposite you I found
that a previously unknown DNA repair
enzyme acts on the substrate we call it
a DNA glycosylase because it leaves a
base sugar bond in DNA in contrast
no places cleave phosphodiester bonds we
reconstituted this base excision repair
pathway repair pathway with purified
enzymes both from bacteria and from
human cells and this is the actual
pathway which I talked about the enzymes
actually act consecutively on the alter
lesion and what you can see here is the
experimental evidence here a stretch of
synthetic double-stranded DNA has been
made that contains uracil residue in the
center of one of the two DNA strands
which is shown here and then it's mixed
with complimentary DNA strand and it can
still be visualized as such by J detect
references and the conditions where the
DNA strands have been separated if
there's uracil in DNA the DNA strand
remains intact of the removal of the
space we have treated it here with an
enzyme that removes the uracil DNA but
the DNA chain still stank hangs together
but an a basic site has been generated
which is susceptible to cleavage by the
next enzyme in the pathway the endo no
place for a base excites the sugar
phosphate residue at the site of damage
is then removed and the DNA polymerase
fills in the gap and finally DNA ligase
seals to the enemy models for various
aspects of this pathway have been
proposed by several groups next slide
please
including us
it is not a simple task for a DNA
glycosylase to find a single uracil best
base in a large excess of DNA so this
repair enzyme acts by scanning the DNA
traveling along the DNA and when it
finds an alteration it flips out the
altered base 180 degrees and so the
riparian can then initiate the repair
process so far I have discussed how
riparian sums can restore damage to DNA
that can be damaged remain but
occasionally an organism can also use
induced changes in the DNA structure to
generate helpful genetic diversity a
striking case of this is the efficient
diversification of antibodies next slide
please
this is an antibody with to change the
heavy and allied chain and the active
site of the antibodies is a variable
region where the specificity of the
antibody is contained in order to
improve the repertoire of various
antibodies an antibody producing cell
can have the ability to actively change
the structure of genes encoding
antibodies by targeted deamination of
cytosine in DNA this idea and the
further processing were due to the
brilliant insight of the late Michael no
burger in Cambridge UK I had a pleasure
to color collaborate with no Burger
loops one specific diamine is AI D
discovered by Hanzo caused targeted
domination of antibody genes
and the uracil DNA glycosylase then
prove processes this lesion and triggers
local mutagenic exchanges which are
reflected in an expanded and more
efficient antibody repertoire next slide
please
so far I've talked about hydrolytic
damage caused by water in DNA but there
are other types of DNA damage caused by
the oxygen we breathe metabolize for
example one particular sinister for more
such oxidative DNA damage is the
oxidation of guanine in DNA to eight
oxygen a toxin gone in for eight Hydrox
guanine in different tautomeric forms
which is shown here and this oxygen is
here but there wasn't oxygen before
which is here this generates miss coding
base and this lesion is excised by a
specific DNA glycosylase which is
different from the enzyme that removes
uracil from beginning next lattice this
shows this process in more detail
oxidation of g most usually results in
removal of this oxidized G by a DNA
glycosylase and local repair process
space excision repair with polymerase
another case if the repair occurs during
actual replication of DNA so the two
process collide the process is a bit
more complex and more mutagenic and this
is what's taken advantage of to generate
antibody diversity
and next like this there are other
endogenous agents in cells than water
and oxygen that can cause DNA damage we
showed that one important example is the
reactive coenzyme a sudden s is messiaen
Yin s a.m. which is shown here and it
easily donates its methyl group s am
such is so reactive that even in the
absence of an enzyme it has a tendency
to donate its methyl group and then it
becomes formerly a methylating agent or
an alkylating agent which will mesylate
other sites in DNA or on other molecules
there are several susceptible sites for
such alkylation on the DNA shown by the
various errors here for example I've
talked about oxidation of or guanine and
you can see that here the sites on go
onion for alkylation the sites are
different so the sites of damage here
are different from the sites that are
damaged by water or by oxygen so we get
new problems new lesions into your name
with regard to alkylating agents there
are three main approaches to deal with
this damage the base in DNA can be
methylated in such a way that it looks
replication of the DNA next at least
this is shown on the right hand side
sorry left hand side the an a residue in
DNA has been methylated to become 3
methyl at the knee
which is shown here and there is a
special DNA repair and some food is
called a IG al killed go on in and this
residue blocks DNA replication so it's
Lisa
dashana this deleterious mutation event
methylation event here of course in the
minor groove of the DNA double helix
which is usually completely free of
methyl groups are the methyl groups in
DNA lactose in Simon for example are all
in the major groove of the DNA but here
we now have a methyl group protruding
into the minor groove of the DNA double
helix and this is a potentially
deforestation man and because it
prevents the DNA polymerases and RNA
polymerase to travel in the minor groove
of the DNA especially parents I'm
excises this methylated base and
triggers again a base excision repair
event this is analogous to the removal
of uracil or oxidized joining from DNA
but in another approach a very mutagenic
base of six methyl Guanella
she's shown here is directly d
methylated by a methyl transferase that
removes this methyl group so this is an
example of direct damage reversal we
don't excite anit nucleotides from DNA
here just the faulty part velocity so
this offending methyl group is
transferred to the repair enzyme itself
to generate a methyl cysteine residue
we use the term suicide in activation
for this event because the whole repair
protein is destroyed by this methylation
about it cannot be regenerated so it is
a costly but effective form of DNA
repair and the reason it can't be
regenerated by cleavage respond here is
that methyl cysteine is an extremely
stable chemical compound you can boil it
in hydrochloric acid without any
alteration so it will be very difficult
to repair this lesion just by removing
the methyl group it's actually easier to
break down the whole methylated repair
protein and make a loop protein instead
more recently we found another DNA
repair enzyme that can remove methyl
groups from the toxic residues one
method adenine and same as the cytosine
in DNA next like this it's shown on this
side and in more detail here one method
adenine and three methyl cytosine now
and the methyl groups are in related or
similar places of the DNA and they are
lethal conditions so it took us many
years to find this enzyme although we
sense that there must be some form of
repair of this damage because this
enzyme has very unusual cofactors that
is I am and a small metabolite
alpha-ketoglutarate they are both
required for this repair action we
proposed and it turned out that this
unexpected demethylation reaction with
DNA using this odd cofactors also is
mimicked in the methylation of histones
which is important for
gene regulation in cells so in
conclusion next like this there are
several common molecules in cells that
can damage DNA and which are impossible
to avoid I've talked about water acid
until assign n ox reactive oxygen and
what water is of course very weak
reagent but it is present at very high
concentration and there are several
other commonly occurring small molecules
in cells that may also damage DNA I
believe that not all of those have even
been found or identified as yet as DNA
damaging agents which suggest that there
are more DNA repair enzymes waiting to
be discovered
but the fact that water is a damaging
agent for tissue components has been
known for 400 years because William
Shakespeare pointed this out next like
this here's the graveyard scene in
Hamlet in which ham that shows himself
to be an excellent scientist by asking a
series of logical and penetrating
questions so Hamlet asks how long will a
man lie in the earth before he rots and
the gravedigger answers in in faith he
will ask you some eight years or nine
years a Tanner will last you nine years
a Tanner is leatherworker and somebody
who cures leather for making shoes
so why he more than other than another
wiser
his hide is so tanned with his trade
that he will keep out water a great
fight and your water is a sore de care
of your wretched dead body and then it
continues Hamlet picks up the skull and
and that leads to his great monologue on
life and death you might know that
already but perhaps you forgot that
Shakespeare in Shakespeare pinpointed
the deleterious effect of water on the
soft components of the human body
including the DNA thank you